data assistant Python this is a
continuation really only from our begin
- course we've tried to keep the
requirements for this data analysis
course as minimal as possible to make it
useful to as wide a range of people at
the University as possible we don't want
people to feel they have to be an expert
in Python before they can start using it
for making their job and life easier so
we only require a relatively small
amount of Python experience but that
said there might be some things in this
course which are new to you so as we're
going through do feel free to ask in the
chat if there's a particular piece of
syntax or particular function that we're
using that you're not sure how it works
please do post the message and ask a bit
of clarification and we'll try and help
out in order to run the session today in
the previous classes we've been using
Jupiter lab which we've installed
through anaconda Jupiter lab we've been
rhyming writing text files with our
Python scripts in and then running them
in a terminal in the session today we're
going to be using a tool called a
Jupiter notebook now it's possible some
of you have used a Jupiter notebook
before so just to get a bit of a sense
of the room could people post in the
chat when they have or have never used a
Jupiter notebook before no good so lots
of people who haven't used them before
so that's gonna be the first thing we go
through today those who have used it
before this first 10-15 minutes or so
feel free to feel free to follow through
it as well otherwise since all the
material is self-guided you can just
carry on through to the next section
without waiting for me to get to it if
you so wish so the first thing to make
sure you've all got is anaconda anaconda
navigator all started up and running so
I'm just going to give you all a minute
or so or 30 seconds or so to start that
up and have it running in the background
before I carry on to actually starting
the session okay so hopefully you will
have anaconda navigator started up now
and running it should look something
like what I see on my screen here you
might have a slightly different list of
apps or you might have slightly
different versions of things but
hopefully it's a similar kind of idea
now I said we were going to be using
Jupiter notebooks today however I don't
want you to immediately click on the
Jupiter note back notebook launch
button if you do want to use that mode
of launching dupes notebooks it's okay
it's going to work just fine and if you
feel more comfortable there that's okay
but for the session today we are going
to use Jupiter lab as the way to start
the Jupiter notebook server I'm going to
explain what these terms mean in a
little bit but if you go ahead on the
Jupiter lab tile which is probably the
first one and click on the launch button
that should open up in your web browser
one I've had earlier that looks
something like this
so I'm just move those to the side so we
can see both of them so click on the
Jupiter lab launch and I'll open up in
your web browser something that looks
like this
head and make this window here
fullscreen and extra fullscreen and the
rest of the session we're gonna be
living inside this window here so
Jupiter lab is a web-based I say
web-based it runs entirely on your local
computer but it works in your web
browser even though it's entirely local
and it gives you an environment where
you can vine Vaughn Python code you can
write Python code one of the things it
has built into it is its own jupiter
notebook environment so the very top
icon you should see in your launcher and
if you've been to our previous sessions
you might not be seeing the same view
just go ahead and you might for example
have something that looks like this just
go ahead and close all the tabs at the
top that's perfectly fine click on the
Python 3 icon under the notebook header
and that would open up a Jupiter
notebook which should fill the whole
screen so having clicked on that Jupiter
notebook Python 3 tile you should get
something that looks something like this
now this is called a Jupiter notebook
I'll just give you 30 seconds or 20
seconds or so to get this started up and
again if any issues closing the chat
what we have here is a Jupiter notebook
a Jupiter notebook is a way of writing
and running Python code in an
interactive way and it also provides us
with a bunch of extra features which are
really useful when we're doing data
analysis kinds of tasks so at the first
case what we can do is we click inside
the grey area here and we can type any
Python code we like I'm going to keep it
nice and simple we can print hello now
if you just press ENTER at the end of
the line it just puts another line
inside that cell so it doesn't run the
code just by pressing enter if you want
to run this cell you either click on the
plus button just above it up there or
hold down shift and press Enter I'll
click the plus the play button this time
but in this course of this session of
what we quite regularly be using shift
enter or ctrl enter Devon the cells so
you will sometimes seem you want
a cell without flicking it and that's
what's happening there if I click the
play button it runs that cell and prints
hello
it also gives every cell that's been run
a number so you keep track of which
order they've been running because in
principle it's possible to rerun cells
that are further up the page after
having one furthest cell was that
further down the page it can get
confusing and we'll try and cover that
later so I'm just going to switch over
to the notes now and copy and paste a
few examples from here so one thing we
can do as I said before is have code
over multiple lines I'll just show that
by typing so a equals five B equals
seven a plus B if I do shift enter it
runs that cell and just plays 12 on the
screen notice here in the second case I
haven't had to write print a plus B I
didn't need to do this because the way
that Jupiter notebooks work is whatever
the last thing in a cell is will be
displayed on to the screen so here
because a and B has the value 12 it's
displayed 12 underneath the cell as the
output for that cell and you see the
output and the input have got
corresponding numbers as well as being
able to run Python code as we have done
in the script so far it also gives us an
extra ability to make extra bility to
display output from commands in a
slightly more visually pleasing way now
don't worry about what this bit of code
here does we're going to be discovering
how these things work throughout the
session today I'm just moving my fun bit
they go I'm gonna be discovering how
this works our session today do you want
this it's gonna print something that
looks like a nicely presented table of
numbers where you hover over it and the
lines get highlighted which is useful
when you have larger tables of data the
thing that's really useful however is
the ability to display plots so here
again I'm just copying pasting this in
we'll be discovering how these things
work throughout the course if I won this
cell with shift enter we get a plot
coming up in line so if you use
something like Mathematica or I think
mat
I can do this and our notebooks do this
too it lets you run code and get the
output from that code right there and
then you can carry on further underneath
and you know print whatever you want and
you've got the code in line at the point
where you ask the figure to be shown the
final thing that it allows you to do is
as well as having cells which contain
code at the top of the window there's a
drop-down menu that says code at the
moment and with this cell selected if I
change that to say markdown if I click
on the markdown button on the drop down
menu you see the square brackets the
beginning of disappeared and now this
won't accept python code and run Python
code it will instead accept markdown now
markdown is a way of applying formatting
and design to plain text so you can
start headers by doing a hash key and
you can write header and then if we run
that cell you see it turns the word
header into a big word header you can
then double click on it to edit it you
can write bold text and italics all I
could if I could spell correctly and you
see it formats it with bold and italics
and so what this allows you to do is to
interlace with your code blocks of text
which describe what your code is doing
and the real powerful thing about this
is it gives you the ability to write a
whole report with introduction sections
bits explaining your science or whatever
is the or doing intersperse that with
the code which is executing your
analysis and take that whole report and
compile it to something like a PDF and
allow you to give that out to people as
this is all the stuff I did and the
codes all in there as well on top of
that it also allows you to give the
notebook to other people so that they
can take this app what you've written
and they can run it themselves and see
if they can reproduce your outputs a
particularly famous example of this
though it's becoming more and more
common these days was the LIGO
collaborate
when they were looking for gravitational
waves published all of their results as
do two notebooks with the data provided
alongside them so that people around the
world citizen scientists could download
these files and run the same analysis
that was performed by the people at the
LIGO collaboration and see if they could
reproduce the science have a go at
tweaking the numbers playing around with
things and see if they could discover
anything in there as well so it's a
really good way of getting engagement
with people outside of your local small
field and giving them the ability to
play around with the code there and then
so there was a question in there that's
now looking fine so yes there's a
question there about the plot not
showing up there's two things firstly it
sometimes takes a few seconds for the
plot to appear because it's running the
code secondly you sometimes have to run
the cell twice for a plot to appear that
supposed to be what this magic little
line at the top means that you don't
have to run it more than once but if
your plot doesn't show up just one that
cell again and it should then show up so
to give you all a chance to have a
little play around with dupes notebooks
I'm going to scroll down to the bottom
of that first page in the documentation
and there's exercise there which
contains a block of code so what I'd
like you to do just for a minute or two
to get a handle on this stuff is to copy
that code into a few cells in your
notebook and I'll just switch back to
the notebook a second you can add new
cells if you click in a cell by clicking
the plus button at the top you can add
as many cells as you like by pressing
that button there so we need to take
this block of code split over multiple
cells and in between some of those cells
add a little markdown block which
describes just in a few words as a
comment what the next little line of
code does I'm gonna be going through
that on the screen myself just to give
you an idea of what that demonstration
looks like and I'll just give you a few
minutes to have a play with that
yourself canal asks is there a shortcut
for adding cells yes there is so when
you've got a cell selected and the
cursor is flashing inside there
if you press escape you'll see that the
cursor has disappeared is no longer
flashing inside the cell but the cell is
still selected
in this mode here if you press the a key
on your keyboard like this it puts
another cell below where you are and if
you want to add a cell above where you
are you can press the B key on the
keyboard I think yes it's the B key and
that will add a cell above where you are
how can I go back and V one so if you
want to where you can move up and down
with the arrow keys if you want to rerun
all the cells from the start if you go
to the colonel bottom at the top and
there is a restart colonel and run all
cells button and that will get
everything running from the beginning so
yeah just take a minute or so now just
have a play with that example and I'll
do the same in my in my window here and
again any questions please do post in
the chat and one of us will be there to
help you Olivia
asking how do I add the text bit if
anyone's happy carrying on just carry on
for the minutes while I answer some
questions so Olivia if you select a cell
so you've got it blue like this at the
top here there's a drop-down menu by
default code is selected because that's
the default cell type change that to
markdown and one thing you'll see happen
is that the square brackets in front of
it disappear so that's how you know you
in markdown mode and not in code mode
click inside the cell and there you can
type something like header so your hash
and a space that looking in the line
makes it header two stars makes bold and
an underscore makes italic and if you
use the back tick key on your keyboard
which everyone's keyboards different
then - in the top left you can write
code block like that and I'm going to
copy that into another cell so that
we've got the example and the real one
so this code here generates something
looks like this underneath that answered
your question Olivia
great and Rob your cells aren't showing
the answers after running so if you
could post in the chat there what you've
typed into yourself and then I'll see if
I can reproduce it on the screen okay
I'll come to you in a second canal so
the first two things in the exercise if
I copy those two lines there for example
and I type that into a code cell if I
run that cell there you're saying you
don't see any output and that's correct
you don't see any output because in this
case here the last line of code and I
say line in inverted commas I know you
can't see me but I am the last line of
code in that cell doesn't have a value
because it's assigning it to a variable
and the act of assigning something to a
variable in Python kind of soaks up the
value that you would have been passing
in and so this line of code here doesn't
have an output of any kind
it's just performing a side-effect and
so you don't get any output from here if
we put in this cell my purchases and
then purchase there we go and run that
there we do get an output because that
line has a value and come on how would I
tell you to run several cells together
so I don't know let's try something if I
select two cells at once which I can do
by clicking on one hold down shift and
clicking on another if I press play it
looks like they both won so you can
select a cell select another cell with
shift enter or ctrl enter I think works
and then press the play button and both
of them should one however the easiest
way to get that to work is to go to
kernel at the top restart kernel and one
all cells and now all one everything
okay it's a question here by the other
thing was in this drop-down menu so you
see one that says raw that's basically
in the mode where you want to generate a
PDF Jupiter won't do anything to the
cell before just putting in the PDF so
it's just really really basic and war so
you never need to use that one I'm
heading I don't know what that one does
I'm guessing it's just a shortcut for a
markdown cell the only two cell types
I ever use is code and markdown that's
all what I've ever needed okay so hope
you all have a chance to have a little
play around with a notebook it does take
some getting used to
I do strongly recommend getting used to
using some of the keyboard shortcuts so
it's gonna make your life a lot easier
if you keep your hands in the keyboard
rather than moving around so for example
I'm in this cell here I can press escape
to deselect the cursor press up on the
keyboard and then press Enter and then
now I'm typing into the cell above if I
press escape there and press B I'm now
in the cell below I can press ENTER and
then type a equal seven for example I
can run that with shift enter and I can
move down for bottom cell here and then
run that cell again for example I don't
know that without touching the mouse at
all that's going to make your life
easier as you become more accustomed to
using Jupiter notebooks okay so moving
on to the next section here first thing
we're going to do is in the notes at the
bottom of every page as a next bottom go
ahead and click on that next button now
and in general Christopher will probably
be posting into the chat the link to the
current page we want but in general you
should register follow through in the
order I'm going I think Christopher
might be having some other question at
the moment so introduction to pandas so
this course is about data analysis in
Python because it's a very very common
thing that people in all walks of the
university have some kind of data they
want to analyze maybe it's in a
spreadsheet maybe it's in a text file
maybe it's downloading from a website
often what they want to do is ask a few
questions about it for example to select
a subset of the data or to merge it with
another form of data and often to plot a
graph at the end a lot of science comes
down to a bit of analysis and plotting a
graph as I'm sure you're all aware so
the idea of this course was to get
people to the point where they can do
that set of tasks without having to
without having to do sort of too much
complicated
we want to find a a critical path to
getting this solution done so in pandas
the primary tool that provides these
features that you need to do those
things is a tool called pandas now
pandas is a third party module it's not
core Python it's written by people
around the world writing stuff in their
own free time written by people like you
and me but it's included by default in
anaconda which is one of the reasons we
use it but the reason it's included by
default in anaconda is because it's by
far one of the most popular Python
packages out there it provides a couple
of basic pieces of functionality the
first of which is a series which is what
we can be covering first and the second
is a data frame which we'll come on to
in a little bit but to get a little
sense some people in the room could you
let me know if you've ever used pandas
before or if you ever done anything with
pandas or just had to work on code with
a youth pandas before so we're seeing a
few people yes people would know okay
good so lots of people have never used
it before you're the perfect target
audience however those who have used it
before hopefully you'll go through some
things which will clarify stuff explain
how stuff works underneath and again if
there's anything that you you're really
comfortable with feel free to move
through a little bit faster or ask
questions about how you can do other
things about it and in the chat yeah so
a few people used it most people haven't
wonderful as I said planners provides a
few different tools the first of which
is the series now I Series in Python in
in pandas Zoey you can access by
importing it from the pandas module so
I'm going to start a new notebook and
I'm gonna do that by clicking on the
plus button up in the top left where
says new launcher and I'm going to
select a cube tooth Python 3 notebook
I'm going to save and close the old one
because we don't need that one anymore
and I'm also going to rename the
notebook by white clicking on the tab at
the top select rename notebook and I'm
going to call this pandas
give me your notebooks a sensible name
is a good idea because just having
everything called untitled one and two
and three isn't gonna make your life
very easy so we start off by from pandas
import series so from the pandas module
we're importing the class series I won
that with shift-enter thinks about it
for a moment and we've got access to a
series I'm gonna copy this line of that
list because otherwise I'll get a
different set numbers to you so the way
that you create a series in pandas is by
calling the series class like a function
and you can provide any lists of data to
the series object because at its core
the series is kind of like a Python list
it works in a very similar way
superficially and we're gonna be
investigating some of the differences
shortly so the easiest way to make a
series is to give it a list of numbers
so here inside the round brackets I've
given it a list numbers with the square
brackets these are all integers in this
situation if I run that cell is going to
because I haven't assigned it to a
variable it's going to display the value
of that object and this is a view we're
gonna have to get very used to see we're
gonna be seeing a lot of syriza's or
whatever the pool is so I'm going to
explain now what the things on this
screen mean and what we should be paying
attention to when we see them now the
first thing you hopefully notice is that
this line of numbers on the right hand
side are the same numbers and in the
same order than those we passed in in
the list at the top 14 7 3 - 7 & 8 so
the first thing to notice is that series
has maintained the order that we pass
things in and that makes sense because
you'd hope that a series is serial and
maintains
ordering the next thing to look at is on
the left hand side we have the numbers 0
1 2 3 4 these are the index you can
think of these as being the bow number
or the vowel able because we'll see in a
while that the row label can be strings
as well as being integers because we
haven't told it what labels want to
apply it's automatically generated the
numbers
starting from zero because remember that
Python always starts counting from zero
the final thing to be aware of is the D
type D type means data type in this case
it is an INT 64 int means integer 64
means it's a 64-bit integer 64-bit
integers can get very large they can get
as large as 2 to the power of 64 so the
largest integer you can have inside this
thing is pretty much that big except
actually it's only that big because he
goes positive and negative so you can
hold very very large numbers inside here
by default the reason that it tells us
what the type is here is because pandas
is going to use the type of the data to
perform certain optimizations as it does
stuff which is useful when we're dealing
with millions of numbers and we want to
do mathematical things to them it's
going to do it nice and fast as I said
here we didn't specify an index so it
generated one for us we can go ahead and
give an index to it index equals so the
second argument to series we pass a list
of well whatever you want but here I'm
going to use a couple of strings single
character strings but strings
nonetheless and when we run that we see
printed out on the screen the same
numbers as before but here we have a set
of indices just say 30 seconds or so now
just to have a go at making sure you can
import pandas you can generate these
series and our way back in a moment to
carry on to the next section
okay got a questionnaire on the chat
from Dan it's impossible to index from a
sliced range okay so you're asking for
example if you wanted to do something
like you wanted to have the numbers so
something like 1 to 6 in there that's
fake syntax that won't work so if you
wanted to do something like that you
should be able to use the range syntax
and do 510 and that will give us no
missing a bracket Alex it's a comma not
there we go so in the index they are
passed in the range function and so it
starts from 5 and gone through to 1 less
than 10 is that what you meant down
great an atom is there a shorthand for
copying a previous line yes there is so
if you've got a cell selected you press
escape so that your cursor is not in
there I think if you press Y and then p
YY and then p nope someone said there's
a as a help if you need it
[Music]
edits copy you see paste is V okay so
you select it if I see and then you put
V there we go
so C to copy just pressing the C bit key
by itself and then V to paste and you
can delete a cell with pressing D twice
I'm not expecting you to remember all of
these there was a way to get the
keyboard shortcuts but I can't remember
how you do it it's probably in there
somewhere if I don't one I can see how
to get the Jupiter notebook help up then
that'll be great okay so let's go ahead
and actually do something with these
things so I'm going to go back to thank
you but with what I've got in the notes
I'm going to go back to this cell here
so I'm going to delete these other cells
so we have here a series I'm going to
assign that to a variable s because I'm
unimaginative see this time because it
assign it to
variable it hasn't rinsed everything out
but we can have a look by whiting s and
then it shows up on the screen escape
and B to draw the cell or press the plus
button there so we want our something of
it I said that series is are like lists
and they are like this in many ways one
of which is that you can use square
brackets to select items out of them and
in this way they're actually starting to
act a little bit more like dictionaries
because we don't put a number in here
per se although you can if your indices
a number you put in here the row label
that you want to select so in this case
here because we labeled them ABCD in
either strings we can pass in here see
we've won that and it gives us back C is
the third item C is the third item so C
gives us what happens to be number three
if we do it with a we get 40 so it gives
us back the value from the the list from
the series Zoey
if you're used to our and they're pandas
they're data frames and so on they would
give you back a list with one item in
which is 14
however plan is just gives you back the
number itself as it is saying that the
value from this list associated with the
value a is 14 we're going to see later
on some more advanced things you can put
inside these square brackets but if you
just put a single item by itself it's
going to look up at that row find the
index label that matches it and return
it back to you you can also edit in the
same way so we can do s and we can edit
I let us edit E and we can set the value
to be something else so we can say this
should be minus 9999 run that it's done
it you sell s and we see that he has
been updated and changed so there's
three exercises after this bit here
don't necessarily worry about doing all
of them in general there's a few more
exercises and you really need they're
just there to stretch you if you're
interested just take a minute or two to
have a go at those and then I'll move on
to the next bit
like squishing their form Adam in the
chat so comparing to MATLAB this is
basically a way of storing data but can
we add in streams as well you absolutely
can
so in the examples here I've been having
integers as my types here if I take my
series example and make a bit space and
do it here you can absolutely put this
is a word actually just funny without
the S at the beginning and you see we've
got some data here which is this is a
word so you can for any kind of data in
here at all you'll notice this time the
D type has changed to object that's it's
sort of generic I don't know anything
more than it's some kind of object that
means that you're losing the ability to
have efficiency and speed when you're
dealing with these things so if you
wanted to do mathematical operations to
this series it would become slower than
it would be if they were all integers
for example in general it's a good idea
for each series to have one kind of data
so have these holders strings or always
integers always folks but it is possible
to mix them together I can I'll
sometimes suddenly my shortcuts stopped
working so if your shortcuts won't work
if your cursor is flashing there so if
you want to for example copy or do a
cell underneath make sure you first
escape so the blue outline around the
cell disappears and it's just gray and
there's no flashing cursor there anymore
that means that when you do something
like a to do a not do a cell above it
works correctly so give that a go and
see if that helps and I'll delete that
so so from those exercises we've just
been going through there there's a
question there about how under zapped
and the series differ from a list of
dictionary and while these ones are
bother just having a play around and
having go with these things yourself
yeah I'll answered this question about
how a series different from a dictionary
and a list I wanted to point these out
because it's useful to have an
understanding because one of the things
you need to get used to in programming
is choosing the right kind of container
for the data you're dealing with and so
knowing how they compare against each
other is a useful first step along that
so they're like dictionaries because you
just accessed by any kind of key but
importantly series are ordered where
dictionaries aren't we'll see later on
that series can have repeated indices so
while you can't have a dictionary with
the same key repeated you can have that
in a series it's generally not a good
idea but sometimes it does make sense so
be aware of that and syriza's are sped
up and made fast by using numpy or numpy
behind the scenes a list again they're
in order and you insects white integer
in principle but a series lets you
access stuff by key as we saw and again
it's made faster so on the whole it
takes the best bits from both and makes
it faster but there are some situations
where you don't want something quite as
difficult to interact with as a series
it's not built into Python for example
so series operations let's have a look
at an example and I'm going to be asking
for some audience participation in a
moment so here we have a list if we
wanted to double all of the items inside
that list let's do something like my
list times 2 now could you post in the
chat there and let me know what's gonna
happen when I do the list multiply by 2
is it going to double all the numbers
and you can cheat by trying it yourself
yeah okay good lots of people saying yes
let's see what happens no that's weird
isn't it so because this is a built-in
Python list and not a series it isn't
making the assumption about it being
numerical data a Python list is just
designed as a container for information
so what it's actually done is he's taken
our list 3 6 8 for 10 3 6 8 for 10 and
it is doubled it and it's doubled it in
of the most literally minded where you
can imagine if he's just repeated itself
again if we wanted to double every item
in the list we'd have to manually loop
over it put the doubled items into a new
list and that takes some time with and
take some lines of code as well with
only 5 items you're not really going to
note any slowdown but if you have a
million items putting in a Python list
and looping over it is going to be slow
so let's take this same list and let's
make a serious call des in fact they
call it s1 has different name from
before and so we're taking our list we
are converting it into a series and
giving it a name
s1 now looks like this so it's those
same numbers but it's a pandas series if
we multiply that by two it's done the
correct thing so it hasn't duplicated
the list it has applied this operation
to each item in the list and because it
knows that they are integers it is able
to do this in a very very fast and
efficient way right so the code will go
green yes so while it's running it goes
green apparently so that's the
difference between the two David so this
allows you to run this numerical
operation on everything inside this list
now this is useful if you've got numbers
inside there and you want to be able to
double them or find averages or things
like this but as well as doing numerical
operations like x 2 or we could do minus
2 that works too
so 3 has become 1/6 become 4 etc we can
also do boolean operations so logical
questions about our data so instead
doing a mathematical operation which
changes the numbers we can ask questions
which are going to give us back to or
folks answers so for example we can say
is s1 I'm gonna change this cell here
just to be s1 so we've got a reference
is s1 greater than 6 and we've run that
and it gives us back the answer but it's
giving us back the answer for every
single though it might look like we're
asking the question of is this whole
series bigger than 6 but actually what
this ends up meaning to scroll down a
little bit what this ends up meaning is
for each item in the list ask each of
them are they greater than 6 so 3 is not
greater than 6 6 is not greater than 6 8
is 4 isn't tennis and so it gives us
back this list of truthin forces
as question they're from Olivia so this
means in this I can only do these kinds
of Asians two looping realistically yes
there are ways to make it look like
you're not looping but you are always
looping so what this has given us here
is ability to ask these questions and
get back to us and forces you see that
the d-type has changed to bool for
boolean we'll see in a moment how we can
actually use these ourselves but have a
quick go now just have a play with the
series - I do multiplications on them
and try doing greater Dan's try less
than or equal to s and things like this
and see what works and see see if you
can get stuff to give you output that
you expect and I'll be back in a few
minutes to move on to the next bit Shan
is asking how do you get just the
numbers from the series so you want to
get not all of the stuff around it you
just want to get the values and you can
get that by writing dot values and that
gives you back the array with just the
values out of there okay great so a few
good conversations happening the chat
there so Beau's asking is numpy faster
than pandas or not so pandas as
Christopher says uses numpy behind the
scenes everything underlying it is numpy
and it's just using pandas as a way of
giving a nice interface on top yeah nice
Christopher says always one step ahead
of me is he I'm going to go again I'm
gonna just make some more space
underneath and I'm going to come back to
our s thing from before I'm going to
change s so that the last item in it as
you know I'm going to redefine it so
that it's the example from before there
we go so
ABCDE and the numbers I showed you
before that with an S you can do
something dear you can do something like
s is greater than let's say greater than
four and it gives us back some chosen
forces now that's useful as a first step
it gives you something which if you look
at with your human eyes you can see
there are two zijn forces and so you
could kind of try and cross check and
you could say okay so which items are
greater than four a is true B is true
and ears true okay so that that and that
have passed my test okay that's good
however we are lazy because we are
programmers the best programmers are
always the laziest programmers because
we make the computer do the work for us
we shouldn't have to do this manually
because software is there to automate
our lives so making another cell below
I'm gonna take this s greater than four
thing and I'm going to kind of double
things off so I said before that when
you write s and you put brackets in it
you can put inside here something like a
the space is here just for clarification
in a moment and the S is here are two
the a here is going to select though a
from s if you saw I said if you put a
single item in here it's going to give
you back that single item however there
is a special shortcut mode that if you
put inside these square brackets
something that is a list of trues and
falses or more specifically a series of
two's enforces it will use that that
series of trues and falses as a mask and
anywhere where there is a false it will
not show the data and anywhere where
there's a true it will show the data so
here we can paste it in our s greater
than four so s greater than four words
inside those square brackets and when we
run that it gives us back just the
things that passed the question now this
here is obviously a simple example it's
just sit asking a small question about
your data is a greater than four but you
can ask more complicated things you can
say if s is x - is it still greater than
four and here we see that we've got
extra data s come through now while C ie
three isn't greater than four itself if
you doubled three to six six is greater
than 4 into a part of the test and so
you can put relatively complex questions
inside your square brackets here and
that's going to give you the ability to
filter down your data and discover the
things from it that you really really
want hopefully throughout the session
today we'll be seeing more examples of
this but at this point I want you all to
have a go at doing that yourself have a
play with the putting different numbers
in here try making different series ease
yourself and see that you can reproduce
this and make sure you understand how it
works if any of you have any questions
about what this does how it works or
what kind of extents you can take it to
please do have a chat with us in the
chat there and apart from that are we
jumping back in again in a minute or so
okay so hope you've all had a chance to
have a little play around with querying
your data like this there are other ways
of querying data in pandas we'll be
seeing how they interact with larger
forms of data in a short while but there
are also other techniques out there
I do recommend having a look through the
pandas documentation after this session
some of it is very technical and dense
but some of it is written for relative
beginners so you should be able to get
some useful information out of it as
well I'll point you towards it - towards
the end of the session so the last thing
I wanted to cover on series which is
going to be useful later on is how you
can do things between two series so here
i've defined two more
I've got s2 and s3 ones got large
numbers in it and the other one's got
smallish numbers in it as before we saw
that we can do s2 minus five that's four
tracks five from all the values inside
s2 so 23 goes to 18 for example but if
you've got two series which are the same
length you can do s 2 minus s 3
and it all subtract the corresponding
elements from the two of them so does 23
minus 7 is 16 5 minus 6 is minus 1 and
so on and so on and again it does this
very quickly it will even if you've got
a million items inside here it will be
able to subtract one the other in a
fraction of a second so you generally
don't have to worry about the speed as
long as your d types are showing up
correctly as in 64 and as long as these
are a similar size thing this is always
going to be a nice nice fast operation
you don't generally have to worry about
that if you do get the point of having
to worry about your data being far too
big will give you some information end
of the session to come and talk to us
about how you can get help after the
session so moving right down to the
bottom of this what was the title of
this page was introduction to Paris
right down to the bottom that page there
was a flat and final exercise here which
I will just go through with you so
create two series of equal lengths with
no specified index containing any value
like almost mathematical operations on
them that's what we've just done there
now what happens if they've got
different lengths let's have a look so
let's make s3 shorter so s2 we've got
five elements in s threes now when
you've got four if you subtract one from
the other I didn't run that cell again
yeah classic thing that happens if you
change a cell but don't run it then the
values that are set inside it don't get
updated so you have to make sure you
always run a cell after having edited it
so here we see that s 2 minus s 3 is
done 23-7 again 16 5 minus 6 minus 1 all
the way down to it's got to 7 take away
4 is 3 then it's twice to do 5 take away
well there's nothing there
and it's important to be aware of the
difference between 5 take away 0 and 5
take away at that point I just paused
because there's nothing to subtract from
it there's no definition of what use if
you do 5 take away something that just
doesn't exist
what the answer should be is not five
it's not infinity it's not anything so
to handle this situation pandas and
generally most Python other foreign
languages have a type called nan which
stands for not a number and so any
situation where you do something that
represents something that isn't a valid
number we'll put a Nam in its place now
Nan's are viral so if you do name a
times three that's going to be a nan if
you do five - nan that's going to be an
an so now it becomes sticky and they
hang around another good question in
there from Anna why they floats now so I
was about to come onto that but I'm glad
you pointed out so 23-7 integer integer
we have a five day window just from
before but now for sometimes it's 16.0
and for the pure mathematically inclined
out there you might think that sixteen
and sixteen point zero might be
technically different things and they
are in programming languages
the reason it's had to do point zero
here and turn them into floats and you
see it's a float 64 it's because the
whole column of values has to be off the
same data type and there is no way to
represent nan inside the integers
integers go from - a big number to
positive a big number and there's no
bits of information left over to
represent nan floats however do have a
special little set of bits built into
them which represent nan so as soon as
your column gets Nan's involved your
numbers are going to turn into
floating-point numbers now some of you
might not be seeing floating-point
numbers here because this is one of the
things that's changed with the recent
release of pandas 1.0 it's now a little
bit different and you can have integers
with names because they do something a
bit clever so in the future this might
not be happening but it's worth being
aware of okay good so with that we are
going to move on to the next section at
the bottom of that page there is a next
button and we all want to data frames
now the term data frame as far as I'm
aware was stolen from the following
language either from the language itself
or from one of the packages I'm not
actually entirely sure
at its core you can think of a data
frame as a table of data so a series is
a one-dimensional list it is something
which just goes along in one direction
they are originally technically designed
I suppose for use as time series so in
our examples before we had indices which
were numbers automatically generated 0 1
2 3 or ABCD but you can have an index
being a complicated value like a
timestamp so a series might be used for
example to store all of the samples from
an experiment maybe that's all of the
temperatures throughout a day or all of
the atmospheric concentrations of co2
throughout year
that's a one-dimensional set where there
is a one piece of information but
repeated and each piece of information
each row has a label saying when it was
collected so that's what a series is a
data frame is a table of data and so
where you can think of a series as being
a column a data frame is a set of
columns all connected together as its
core a data frame is made up of a bunch
of syriza's put next to each other
making up a table that's what they do
and as soon as you start operating on
the data frames start asking questions
from them you are going to start getting
back series's and this is why we've
started with the simpler series type
because very quickly data frames devolve
into a series and that's how you start
operating upon them so we will start by
importing this and I'm actually going to
start a new notebook save the old one
but I'll leave it open it start a new
notebook
and I'm going to call this one data
frames let me start by from pandas
import data frame now as a question the
chat about how often do you have to do
this import generally you do it once at
the very top of your notebook and then
it persists
the rest of that session this next bit I
am going to copy and paste because
there's no where you want to sit here
and watch me type out all of this this
that would be very boring for everyone
involved and I would absolutely
definitely make a mistake so this is
just a plain old Python dictionary each
key is a string and each value is a list
of items each of these three lists are
the same length the way this is going to
work is each key is going to be used as
the label for a column and each value is
going to be used for the values in that
column so we go ahead and run that now
at the moment that's just a plain old
dictionary if you want to turn it into a
data frame we could go ahead and use the
if I could spell data frame class which
we've just imported at the top and we
pass it our data in the same way we
passed our series our our list sorry to
the series there's a convention to name
your date of fame DF and that's a bad
idea because it doesn't describe it so
I'm going to rename this to census I
think that's how you spell census then
in the cell below I am going to print it
out sense so you're gonna see me lots of
typos in this session there we go just
gonna make sure I've got my chat window
open good so you can see here we've got
a table and hover over it and see well
the lines showing up nicely so how can
we just call that we've got three
columns because we had three items
inside our dictionary city en Pop City
Year and pop in the city column we had
Paris Paris Paris Paris and then four
lands in there for ohms we see the same
thing here so it's maintaining the order
of the data at this point we don't care
about our diction anymore
so I'm actually just going to scroll
down to the bit that matters we've taken
our data we've printed it out you can
think of each of these columns as being
a series and you'll see there are three
columns so they're effectively three
series being involved
if you remember before if we see has had
its own index the way that data frame
works is it combines all the indices
from the parts together and gives one
overall index all the way down the
left-hand side and now because we
haven't specified an index its assigned
one for us again the integers displaying
from zero so I'm gonna give you a few
seconds now just to copy and paste and
run that code yourself make sure you can
import the module make sure you do this
line here and make sure you can get to
the point where you've got a table
displaying in your code that give you a
little bit of time there just have a go
at that and then I'll jump back in okay
so I'm not seeing anyone shouting for
help in the chat so I'm going to assume
that on the whole things are working
well and again if I'm going too fast or
too slow please do say something so
there's a few things that we can do with
these data frames first of all you see
this data frame here already fills up
most of my screen I do have my font size
set quite big but if it was up most of
my screen in the case that you've got
hundreds or thousands or millions of
rows this isn't going to be tenable so
one thing you'll often want to do is
just have a little peek the first few
rows of your table just to kind of get a
sense of how it's looking and we can do
that by writing census dot had and you
give a number of how many items you want
from the head of the table in this case
maybe three and you see it prints out
the first three items similarly you can
do sorry tail head and tail beginning
and end these are quite common terms in
foreign languages so you'll see these
coughing up a few times the other thing
that we want to be able to do and is
going to lead into some of the really
powerful stuff we're going to be doing
throughout this session is grabbing data
out of our table so we start with our
census with our with our series when we
put stuff in square brackets if you
remember it would select by row so you
might think you've put sensors one and
you
without this row here but actually the
way that data frames work is that they
select by column first so in here we
have to write something like city that
will give us back the city column so to
reiterate that a series selects by row a
data frame selects by column that's half
true and I'll explain exactly how this
can get more messy in the future if
you'll remember that we selected by row
in our series but we could also put in
those questions with the two's forces
and that worked too and we'll see things
like that carrying on being the case but
on the whole if you just put a single
item in it's going to look for a column
by that name and if we look for
something which is not there it will
give us a big scary read error which if
you scroll down says key ever not there
that's it saying there's nothing by that
name so let's go back to city this is
given us back a series exactly the type
we were dealing with before the only
extra thing that's got is now it's got a
name it says name city and so we can
remember which column it came from we
can check the type of it by wrapping the
type function around it and we see that
it really is a panda's core series
object so that means we know exactly how
to deal with it so let's start the to
that again census square brackets city
so we could say something like I want to
select all of the rows where the city is
Paris because those are the census
information is that I want to do my
subset of my analysis on because this is
a series we went before that boolean
operations on series give us back a list
of billions we expect to get the same
thing and we do indeed get a list of
trues and falses where the truths arose
whereas paris and the forces are
elsewhere now as before we can take
anything that's a list of trues and
falses with associated indices an object
like this and like before we passed it
into s in this case we can pass it into
you census and inside those square
brackets I'm going to copy and paste
this thing here and the reason I put
those spaces around is because the
proliferation of square brackets can get
confusing so these outside square
brackets are asking a question of census
and so they're going to give us a subset
of sensors these inside square brackets
here are selecting the column on which
we're asking this question so this here
is a list of trues and falses it's going
to mask and select down just the rows
from the census table the thing up above
which match this question that's when we
run this we get back just these items
here which match paris have a little go
that yourself make sure that's working
and then i'll count on to the next bit
so we selected here census and to select
a column out of it we just put something
in the square brackets it's quite common
that you actually want to select by the
row index and so to do that you do dot
lock which stands for location not the
best name I know but it does work and if
you put the number 3 in there it's going
to give us back the row that matches the
index 3 so it gives us back
Paris 2010 2 point 2 4 4 so this is a
way you can get rows of data and width
of your panas data frames but it's the
reason it's made a little bit more
difficult than getting the column out is
due to the way that the stuff's laid out
in memory effectively it has to ask more
and more difficult questions and do more
work in order to extract a row than it
does to extract the column you think
columns are pre-prepared
but those it has to go and find the data
and reassemble it into a series so
getting those out is possible it is
slightly slower so it wasn't slow but it
was slightly slower and that's why they
make it a little bit difficult to get
access to we can also add new columns so
here we have census let me have a look
at that table it looks like this so we
can add a new column to it
for example a column called Contin
Tao again spelling catching me out and
we can assign a value to it so this is
going to make a new column with that
name and so the value assigned to it
needs to be a list of numbers to fill
the column with the easiest way to get a
list of values to fill the column with
is to generate one from one of the other
columns so for example let's put some
spaces there to make it clear what's
going on
DF City is not equal to London so this
is going to ask off the city column
where it is not equal to London that's
going to give us back a list of trues
and falses we take that list of trues
and falses and making new column out of
it
it's not called DF is it's called census
thank you there we go
so now we look underneath and we flip
the census table and there's now a new
column here which has got our
information in it and we can then use
this in queries as we go forwards to
delete that we can use the del keyword
which is valid Python in many contacts
but is very uncommon reused and you can
delete a column such that when we then
look at it again census it is now gone
so you can add and delete columns at
will have a go the exercise at the
bottom of the data frames chapter so do
this same thing that I've just been
doing there have it go it's selecting
some data out of it and then see if you
can find all of the cities which have a
population smaller than 2.6 million at
this point I should point out that I've
done a very very bad scientist thing and
I've got a column here with numbers in I
never told you what units they are in I
assume you can work out they're not
individuals because you can't have two
point one four eight of a person they
are in fact in millions so when it says
smaller than 2.6 million it's asking for
value that's smaller than 2.6 have it go
those for a few minutes and then our
update everyone before we jump on to the
break so I want to go through the answer
to one of the exercises there so the
bottom of this page is middle exercise
here select the data for the year 2001
we'll see how to do that first then the
question which city
had the smallest population that year
now to answer the second part of the
question does require a function that
you haven't been taught yet so I'm going
to teach it to you now
and show how we can do this and build it
up stage by stage as Krista was saying
in the chat the best way to solve these
things is to start small do one small
bit at a time and slowly build up your
line because even a line of code like
this one can be a little bit hard to
parse when you're first looking at it so
either build it up part by part or give
temporary variable names to each step
and then use those their names in later
steps but let's get to the exercise we
have make sure I've got my thing hip so
we have DF yeah that is oh no it senses
isn't it teach me for reading off my
notes since this year these are all the
years the first thing we want to do is
grab all the stuff for the year 2001 and
do that by selecting where the year is
equal 2001 trues and falses so let's
pass that back into the census
dictionary it said census data frame so
this is going to give us back all the
bits from census where the census year
column is equal to 2001 there we go
we've reduced our data down now the
question in the exercise was which city
had the smallest population that year so
if you just looked at this and said
Paris by reading the numbers that's a
successful way to answer the question I
can't fault you for doing it that way
but bear in mind you could be dealing
with much larger tables or it might be
running from data which is streaming in
live and so you can't look at it
manually so let's look at how we would
do this using pandas to do it for us the
first thing to look at is we've got this
information here the next question we
want to ask is what data in the
population column is the smallest well
let's start off by getting the
population column that's given us just
the data out of that column with vu 0 4
& 8 notice it hasn't renumber the
indices it's maintained their original
numbers from the original table 0 4 & 8
and what we can do is take this and
assign it to a new variable because I
don't want this line to get too
complicated so I'm going to call this
pop and we've got a variable called pop
which is the same thing but it means
we've always able to refer back to this
set of data if we look at pop let's get
rid of that highlighting we could do min
calling min on a series gives us back
the smallest value in there so 2.14 late
we could use that number and then refer
back to the table find the column so
we'd find the row which has that
population value inside it but that's a
manual process and we want to use the
computer to do our job for us so there's
a function built into it and this is the
one I didn't tell you about called idx
min which stands for index min ie give
me the index of the row which has the
minimum in it in our case the minimum is
this and so the row that index of the
row is 0 so this should return us 0 if
we change this to index max we see we
should get 4 and we do but we don't want
max to be one minute
so given that we now want to use the
fact that we know which row had the
smallest population in the year 2001 by
going to our census table grabbing the
city column because we want to get the
city out at the end of it all as you
know let's do it the other way round
let's do this no let's do city column
first city which gives us back the city
column and then that's a series so we
can ask a question of the series like
chaining together these square brackets
and put inside there this question we
asked this is 0 so it's going to get the
zeroth row from the column here we won
that and it prints out Paris so that is
how we answer this question remembering
that pop is actually this thing here so
if you wanted to we could copy that we
could use our thing here the place pop
with it get rid of these spaces
and one that we should get the same
answer we do and we look at that line of
coke there you realize why I split this
onto multiple lines with multiple
variable names because while this answer
the question is very dense and difficult
way of understanding it
we've got just over an hour left today
so we've got two main topics on to get
through still the first of which I'll
jump into now and want to make sure we
get round to making plots before the end
of the session because for a lot of you
that's going to be the reason that you
came so I've made a new notebook here
still what my old ones open so we can
refer back to them but we're going to
start off let me just get my notes up
we're going to start off going through a
how we go about reading a file so
switching back to the notes planners has
built into it lots and lots of ways of
reading files from either from your
local hard disk or even downloading them
directly from the internet it's got a
variety of tools for different file
formats one of the most common you're
going to see is comma separated values
CSV files but I would not be surprised
if many of you are also dealing with
Excel spreadsheets in some domains
you'll also come across file types such
as hdf5
or even SQL or sequel databases to
beyond that there are a number of other
file formats which Pandor supports but
those in my experience are by far the
most common to show how planners gives
us the ability to read in these
different data formats and to deal with
the inevitable messiness that comes with
them and we're going to go through an
example now in my experience files that
you're reading in are never quite in the
format you want them to be you might
wish that they were perfectly laid out
neat everything they are nothing missing
but realistically the real world gets in
the way and we have data which is messy
either it's poorly presented poorly laid
out or just have stuff missing from it
so if you've already gone to this page
we had to update the page in the break
because something had changed and it
wasn't working anymore
so make sure you refresh this page
before you carry on copying the examples
so I'll refresh that now to make sure
mines are fished there we go
refreshed so here is a CSV file example
it's available at this link here so this
here is the contents of that file it's
got some text at the top which describes
what's going into the file and sort of
an explanation about what's inside it
then it's got the actual tab
day two itself you'll notice it's using
semicolons instead of Commerce to to
delineate the different columns in the
table it says up here I miss a minus one
signifies a missing value so we've got
some minus ones which mean there's no
census data for that year there's also
some places where we've just got two
semicolons let's switch other and that's
meaning that in this gap here there's
again missing data says lots of missing
data
it's an estranged format it's got some
stuff at the top we can have to deal
with I'm going to go through now how we
can deal with this stuff and how we can
get pandas to read it in in a nice way
so we start off by importing pandas
there is a convention that when you
import pandas you import it as PD it
doesn't matter you could do all this
just with import pandas but when you
come to finding examples online you'll
see people using PD dot something quite
a lot so it's worth getting used to
seeing that make sure that's imported so
that functions we're gonna be using
today is something called PD dot read
underscore CSV there's a whole bunch of
weed underscore something's if that
let's just have a quick look at them
this is just loading up we had CSV fwf
jason HTML etcetera etcetera I won't
read all them out but there's a lot as
you can see the nice thing that's
Jupiter notebooks give us is that if
we've got a function and we don't know
how to use it we can just use a question
mark and then run that cell and it's
going to print out the documentation for
it and you see here the documentation
for V CSV is long this is an example of
what might be considered a bad function
because it's got far too many arguments
to it but it's one of those situations
where they've tried to find the balance
between functionality and usability on
the whole I think they found it
correctly but there are a lot of
arguments these are just the arguments
and the default values scroll down
further and it has a description of each
and every argument in there so we're
gonna be referring back to this along
the way so that we can see what we need
to do so that end I'm actually going to
switch back the notes here and there is
a link after import panas PD
to the manual so I'm going to click on
that link and this is that same thing
but on the web page it's going to be
easier for us to search through it on
the web page so the first thing we do is
pass in the file that we want to read
now I've prepared a file for you at a
link which I'm going to copy and paste
there again this is in the notes this is
just finding a string we are going to
pass that string to the read CSV
function and then we have it
it has download the file opened it as a
CSV file and is attempted to interpret
everything that's inside it as you can
see it's done a job but it hasn't done a
brilliant job it is naively assuming
that everything in there is a CSV file
and it's asking for us to explain
anything that's outside of that loose
convention so the first thing we'll see
is it included the comments at the top
all that stuff that was explaining what
was inside the file I'm going to
reorganize this you can do this in
Python you can have a function call with
arguments one on each line and I'm going
to have to use another argument to this
function tell it that it should skip
some of the rows so I'm going to go to
the documentation and I'm going to do
ctrl F and search for skip skip initial
space let's do match highlight war skip
rows ah that sounds like the one we want
so let's look for skip rows skip those
and go down the page and here is the
documentation for that argument
it says the line numbers to skip that's
what we won't want to tell it how many
line numbers we want to skip so let's go
back to here and pass in skip those
equals and I think it is five we want to
skip because there were four for comment
the three comment lines then two blank
lines we've run that there we go those
comments the top have disappeared and
already is looking a little bit better
we've just got the data left over the
next thing is that this CSV again in
inverted commas isn't using commas to
separate the values it's using
semicolons because I was trying to be
deliberately obtuse when I designed this
file so that we could learn together
so again we go back to the documentation
and go to the top and we want to find
out how
tell it which thing it should use to
separate the columns so let's just start
looking for Sep ah there we go
Sep there's an argument called SEP which
if we go down to the limiter to use now
delimiter means the thing you use to
separate stuff if it's none it tries to
guess what it is and it assumes that
it's a comma and you see here the
default is it's the comma so let's do
set equal and then it's a string it's a
semicolon
use as and so now we run this and there
we go we're basically there so we've had
to tell it what file what to skip and
how to separate it and it's pretty much
done the white job we've seen those
places where we had those consecutive
semicolons we've now got Nan's showing
up because there was missing data they
are not numbers than or zero population
of zero is a valid population these are
not values however you will see that
there are these minus ones in there and
if you remember from the documentation
that we had at the top of the file it
said a minus one signifies a missing
value the locusts partly that it's
changed into a minus one point zero zero
zero again because of the whole nan
thing it's converting them all into the
same data format but we want to tell it
that minus one is not a valid number it
is in fact actually magnifying missing
data so there we can write let's have a
look through it's a little browse at the
top this is generally the way that I
work but I'm using a library I sit here
and I stare at this and see if I can
work out what's going on so let's try
searching for nan ah nan na they're
using here okay so in a filter true na
values there's something to get any
values and scroll around the page it's
what on the page additional strings to
recognize as nan okay so we give it a
list of strings and it's going to use
them as nan values in a values equals
minus one and now we should see these
minus ones turn into nan so let's watch
that happened three two one BAM there we
go
it's now representing all the missing
data as Nan's
the last thing we might want to do is
that here we have three columns which
contain data some of them missing some
of them aren't do we have a column here
which is unique and in a census you
would normally use the year as the
primary index by which to say which year
you care about you say the first thing
you thought about is which year you're
talking in we haven't told it what index
to apply to our data frame and so it's
generated the 0 1 2 3 defaults however
we can tell it that it should use this
column as the index and so it will take
these numbers and use them as the index
and have it not as a column of its own
and we do that by passing in the index
Col argument let me switch to the
documentation index call columns to use
as the variables that's exactly what we
want to do equals yeah we run that we
see the years become bolded it's now
down there and we've got our data frame
all working together and because we've
done that means we can do something like
a census equals this census like we did
before
get a city column oh hey I know it's not
cool City anymore is it
it's called let's get the this different
layout just get the information for
London and you see here it's giving us a
series with the columns being of the
years which means we can say something
like 2001 and it gives us back the
population for London in the year 2001
this is very easily navigate down our
data so for the exercise here go to the
bottom of the reading from file chapter
and there there is a link to and I'll
just go there myself there's a link to
this DAT file so do the same thing that
I just did but doing it over this DAT
file instead and if we look at that file
ok it's not gonna let us it can side it
that's annoying
yeah actually have a look at where it
came from when the Met Office website
loading loading loading loading loading
that's not gonna load so in the meantime
just take that URL there and paste it
into the same read CSV thing we did
above and try doing that same thing
which by just fiddling with the data try
adding in skip rows changing the
separators things like that and see if
it starts to look how you want it to and
if you get stuck have a look at the
answer and otherwise I'll go through
with it go through you all with it in a
little bit once you've had a chance to
play yourself okay so you've got a
question in chat from Jessie let me just
get that loaded up so you're watching
the string here and you run it and it's
saying invalid syntax and the reason
that's happening is because on Windows
they use the backslash character to
represent folder separators however in
almost every programming language
backslash is used for control characters
so for example backslash n is a newline
and so it's reading your string here and
seeing this is backslash capital u which
i think is how you write unicode
characters and backslash w is something
else etc so one thing you could do is
replace all your slashes with forward
slashes because they work fine on
Windows otherwise as Chris says do an R
at the beginning of it which makes a
wall string and then that will work
successfully okay so I'm just going to
go through the first part of the
exercise there's the first part was just
to open the file and get it all wet
incorrectly so leaving that other stuff
on the screen there I'm just going to
paste that in and I'm going to comment
out the magic bits so we can kind of
build it up bit by bit yeah feel free
while I'm doing this to just carry on
going the exercise yourself if you've
done this already you don't have to
listen to me feel free to carry on
through the other bullet points looking
at negative temperatures etc but for
those who are interested I'll just go
through this on the screen so we read
the CSV in from that file I've commented
these out - those aren't being applied
and we look at it and it looks
all wrong all the files are in the wrong
place it's got all this extra
information at the top which we want to
skip in the same way we did with
everything else so we run it again with
the Skip header suddenly we're getting
data that looks correct again it's
assuming that it's comma separated
values but our table as we saw saw was
not comma separated they're separated by
spaces so we want to tell it that
instead of using commas you should use
white space to separate the columns and
if we now want this we see that it works
I'll point out one thing about this data
because we are gonna be using in the
next section and in fact the other
exercises the Year column here isn't the
year in which the data was measured it
is the average temperature for that year
in the same way that the october column
is the average temperature in october
the final thing we have to look at and
if we look at the end of the table it'll
be clearer with tail in 2019 there's a
bunch of 99 9s at the end and that's
because i downloaded this file and put
it on the website in october twenty
nineteen six months ago and so there's
obviously no temperature data for the
future from their perspective now it
tells us in the format on the metas
website that minus ninety nine point
nine and - ninety nine point nine nine
both represent missing data in the same
one that i'm minus one did before and so
we can use the n/a values to set them to
names so when we run this we see the
Nan's showing up with a bottom that last
bit there is very easy to miss it's also
very easy to miss the difference between
with one nine in the decimal place and
with two nines in the decimal place is
this question though about whether
de-limb white spaces the same as slash s
plus it's a very good question and in
fact i can answer it by going to the
documentation and looking for de-limb
white space
and it says right here equivalent to
setting SEP is equal to / S Plus now
this for those who haven't come across
it it's called a regular expression
these are very powerful ways of matching
patterns which we don't cover in this
course if you are experienced with them
you recognize what this means in essence
it means a bunch of white space but to
avoid people mean to know regular
expressions they've added in the delimit
space argument to make that easier for
people bo asked how can I set all
negative values as nem so there I don't
believe there's a built-in way to do
that using n/a values unless you have
only have a subset you know a strict set
of negative values you're dealing with
the way that I would deal with that is
to read the data in and then do a second
pass where I loop over that column or
apply a function to that column which
replaces any negative numbers with Nan's
so as a function called apply which
applies a function give it to every row
every item in a series and you could do
a if statement inside that function
which would check things out which would
compare it to zero and then return none
if it was less than zero so I would do
it as a second step after the meeting in
I don't think we'd CSV has got built-in
functionality you could argue that we
des filles got enough arguments already
without adding it anymore
yeah exactly as chris was done there so
I'll see if I can demonstrate that so
let's get rid of the n/a values one here
and it just has these nine nine nines
and if we on the row below do DF where
DF is less than 0 is equal to none so
that's going to find all the places
where the DF is less than zero and it's
going to set them to be none so when we
run that and then look at DF tail let's
see if it's worked
Christopher's reputation is on the line
it did indeed work so out it as a second
step okay so I assume that people have
managed to read in that data file using
example in
notes and I should point out again I
don't actually I say again I don't know
if I have pointed it out yet on every
exercise there is almost always I think
always and answer link if you click on
that it will take you to the answer
where this is the lines of code that I
just copied and pasted from so there's
ever an exercise you're stuck on you can
always find out the answer and get a
little bit of help but do try and have a
go yourself with these things first so
I'm gonna have a look at these other two
exercises here how many years has a
negative average temperature in January
and what was the average temperature in
June over the years in the dataset so
there's a few kind of slightly more
complex questions we might want to ask
there but the sort of thing that if
you're doing reach rhetorical data are
other kind of questions you might want
to be asking so the first thing there
was how many years had a negative
temperature in January so we've got our
DF which again shouldn't be called DF
because that's a bad name it should be
called temperatures but let's just carry
on for now let's start by looking at
January because that's the month that we
care about that's the column if we ask a
numerical mathematical question of that
or a logical question of that it's going
to give us back another series so we can
say we're Jan is less than 0 that's
gonna give us all of our negative values
you see it's done focuses its dot in the
middle because that jumps in 1663 to
there's several centuries of weather in
the middle some of them are going to
have an average 0 average January of
less than 0 but for some reason the
first 5 in the last 5 don't we take
these foods and foxes and we pass it
back in to DF and that's filtered down
our data so we see that all of these
first column here values should all be
negative so 1684 1695 1709 etc all have
negative values if we want to find out
how many there are in here the easiest
way to do it is to pass call the Len
function on the list no my computer's
trouble is there we go
so I've just passed this data frame into
Len no I need to like it's a different
answer in my notes because I've got an
extra pair of square back into their
that I've been accidentally there we go
so DF journey is less than zero
DF of that there we go
is 20 so there are like 20 rows which
have a average January temperature of
less than 0 I think there is also
another way of doing it which I'm going
to try and work out live with you all in
front of me which is always a risk when
you're programming there's a bunch of
functions you can call on data frames so
the result of this whole thing here is
that it's a data frame so there is for
example I think it's summary
no not summary count this is where I
should look at the documentation but I'm
being the one kind of lazy so there we
have a cool counter data frame it tells
you for each column how many items are
inside it I think by default it doesn't
count names but it will count anything
that's not an app so here's another way
we could have done it we could have said
data frame of January count or if we
wanted to we could have taken from our
data frame we could have grabbed just
the January values and then we could
have called dot count on that which
would have given us 20 as well there is
as they say more than one way to skin a
cat
I don't like skinny cats at all but if
you're going to you can do it with code
the other question that was in the notes
which I just moved out for was what was
the average temperature in June over all
of the years in the data set so again an
average temperature in June thing to
start with is looking at the June column
here's a bunch of data if you want to
find the average of a series because
number when you get a column out of data
frame that gives you a series there was
a function called meme which you just
call directly on the series and it
returns you the single value of the mean
14 so over the last several decades in
some measurement location in the UK
where
which is where this temperature data was
collected the average June temperature
or the average of the averages I should
say is fourteen point something degrees
if we look at the Jan temperature we see
the average air temperature is three
this tells us we are probably in the
northern hemisphere
yes question there about why the first
example I did up here didn't work I
think it's because I accidentally missed
off D F there when I was typing and
overvote it so it was giving us the
length of this list which is a list of
length one and so it was just giving us
20 we could actually I think have not
doing that at all and that gives us I
cannot give us all of the truth and
focus ability 361 so we want to be able
to select just the data from it that is
has the true value which is those that
are matching this predicate 30 so
there's a question there how do you set
the index column if it doesn't have a
name that's a good question so the data
we were dealing with here actually had
its first column the one that had the
dates inside it didn't have a name I'll
just see if I can I don't think I have
the original file anymore let's have a
look this is a peek behind the curtain
at the material one thing I didn't point
out earlier is that the website you're
reading for the notes all of the
everything on there was written using
Jupiter notebooks so these are actually
notebook files which could get get
compiled into HTML and present it to you
but let's have a look at the file that
we're dealing with this one here so
you'll see here this first column here
with the numbers in doesn't have a
column title and so canvas has taken a
guess and has decided that this must
therefore be used as the index that
makes sense and so it's decided to use
it as the index if you have a column in
there which doesn't have a label then
what I would normally do is explicitly
tell it what the label should be so
instead of it having read the file for
the labels I would say give these the
names year of measurement January
February March etc etc yeah or average
then once that's done I would use the
labeled that I've now
given a label as a thing I pass to the
set index function to say use this
column as the index so I do it again in
kind of two stages so Jessie your
question about you've got a list there
can use a mask expression to find values
I don't think so I'm often wrong so
let's have a look at the documentation
see do I have open or Matt you know I
don't and let's have a look at any
values I did skip over earlier so any
values takes a scalar like just a number
a string a list like or a dictionary and
it is optional by default it's this so
there's no option here for the type of
this to be a function so there's no
ability here to pass in something which
is either a function or something which
maps something so built-in there's no
ability to do that so I would suggest
using the feature that Christopher found
for us earlier where we did commented
that out and then we did nope sorry we
did DF DF less than zero equals none
instead of doing DFS and zero you could
do some other clinical inside there so
back to the notes here been through
these exercises we've over open embed
these this type of a file make sure you
keep that bit of code around I'm gonna
be using in the next section we have
done some questions on the data we've
asked about negative annual temperatures
and the average temperature in certain
months and this is the useful kind of
things you do so obviously in this
course we can't get fully into depth
about doing every single type of
analysis we have another course which
will be running a few times after Easter
so in the next month or two called
applied data analysis in Python and
there we actually learn some analytical
techniques for studying more complicated
things about your data but a lot of time
you just want to do relatively simple
filtering and that's what we're doing in
these sections here and the other thing
that you often want to do your data is
not to look at it in a form that looks
like this
I mean it's nice to be able to look at
your data in the table but really you
want to be able to see a better visual
way of representing it so for example
here we see they've got eleven and we've
got thirteen and we've got other things
happening it's hard to see trends in a
table because you can't see anything
really happening you can see a bit of a
trend see look at the July temperatures
they slightly go up there 13s up to
sixteen you know there's maybe a trainer
there but it's hard to see in a picture
so we are going to move on to the next
section which is plotting got just over
half an hour left which is perfectly on
time moving on to the next section which
is the map lot Lib URL and plotting data
with map lot Lib Papillon Lib is the de
facto default plotting library for
python if people could just post in the
chat whether they use map only before or
not that would be an interesting sign of
sample to get a sense of where people
are yeah so there's a lot more people
saying yes they've used it I mean I I
wouldn't expect everyone to have by any
stretch but you it's hard to avoid using
map Lally but if you've ever done
anything sciency in python now what i'm
going to show you in this first section
here while it uses matplotlib you don't
actually need to know any map or label
at all it's a very shortcut e way of
doing things because pandas has built
into it a an interface to matplotlib
which does all of this stuff for you so
let's have a go at doing some of this
stuff so i'm going to leave my DF here
which is our weather data the simplest
way to plot something is to take
something like a data frame and do a dot
afterwards type for letters to brackets
and then run them self and and it score
that's everything you have to do one of
the things I really love about pandas is
they've optimized it for the most common
use cases it's very common that you want
to just draw all of your data and just
have a look at it and looking at this
plot here can any of you see anything
wrong with it post in the chat if you
can see what's funny about this plot
yeah exactly David the y-axis is going
down to minus 100 yet if we look at our
table
we see that all of our numbers are oh
hang on looks like I made a mistake when
I was playing ramen showing you the
examples I accidentally forgot to change
it back so these - 99 s weren't in there
and this really illustrates one of the
brilliant reasons to use plotting it's
not just for having something to put
inside your paper you can publish at the
end of the day it's so you have
something which can visualize the shape
of your data very quickly and easily so
looking through this table we might have
seen these - 99 s because they're at the
end but if they happen to be in the
elided section the middle there's no way
we would ever have noticed them without
doing a plot so doing a plot immediately
draws on the screen we see the green
down here behind the act behind the the
the legend you can just see the line
going down all the way to minus ninety
nine point nine so what we want to do is
go back to our reading function which is
further up the page where is it here it
is make sure we've uncommented out this
bit here because I was doing a
demonstration one than that and then I
have another DF we see that DF is now
nananananana Batman and when we plot it
now we see our data while not pretty
is now at least laid out with the
correct values so the next thing you
would usually want to do when you're
plotting something is not plot all of
your columns all in one big plot you'd
want to kind of pull out some kind of
particular piece of information and so
instead of doing DF dot plot we can
instead do DF yeah oh so I forgot the
quotes so DF here that is our series if
you do plot on a series this one here is
plotting a dataframe
this one here we'll put a series we get
just that set of data we get a plot of
that time series and this is where you
see the very sad fact right in front of
your eyes from publicly accessible
information that definitely on average
over the last 400 years the temperature
of this part the UK at least
has been increasing there's a certain
trend of I know looks like 1 or 2
degrees which is fairly significant when
it comes to the mass of air in the
atmosphere so this I think is a really
nice way of seeing actually global
warming happening right in front of your
eyes now a plot by itself like that is
nice we can see our date and is good for
exploring things but you usually want to
actually do something to your data you
want to be able to label it and give
some information to your reader and the
way we do that is we say we take the
result of this DF year plot thing which
as it happens is the thing that's being
printed out here it's a map Lib thing
and let's give it a name so we can refer
to a label later so year plot 1 that
again same thing happens but now it's
been stored inside this variable and
because we've stored it in that variable
we can do things to it we can say year
plot dot set Y label is temperature and
then we'll run that we'll get a Y label
appear on the left hand side oh I can't
spell thank you yeah there we go now
that's all showing up how we wanted to
and temperature is showing up on the
left hand side now in the notes you
might notice I've got some weird stuff
going on we're after temperature I've
written this dollar sign dollar sign
circumflex slash circ C and we can are
with the beginning and this bit in here
if any of you are I've used a tech or
tech before it's a way of representing
sort of mathematical symbols
this means superscript draw a circle
that's gonna do a small superscript
circle and let us see the R here is
needed the same as I said earlier so the
backslash isn't interpreted by Python
when we run this we get all of the
packets at one place here we go
we get degrees C so you should always
have your units on there
so have a go at that yourself reading
the data plotting the thing the
exercises are further down the page just
above halfway about a third of the way
down we produce that plot by tweaking
the labels try putting the X label on
see if you can guess what the function
is to set the X label try plotting some
different months and then we'll move on
to the next a little bit so David as to
your question about what kind of object
R is everyone else you just carry on for
the minute you don't need to listen to
this I will demonstrate in summary it is
the same thing so if we look at type no
I could spell I would type of hello it
is a string if I look at the type of our
hello it is also a string so the way
that Python uses this are in front of it
is it kind of uses it to pre-process
what's literally written here before it
turns into a string
normally Python reads a quote and it
happy plods along until it sees another
quote and it does stuff to things in
between like new lines what the are he
does is it changes the way that it reads
through this string before making a
string out of it and what the R really
means is don't do anything until you see
another closing quote Adam to your
question about square brackets and round
brackets as Christopher says exactly
right square brackets used for indexing
and round brackets used to call
functions when it comes to things like
pandas it's a little bit more complex
than that it's completely true that
that's what it does but I tend to think
of it more about square brackets are
used to ask queries of the data because
you can do more than just ask for single
index you can parse in for example that
series of truth' enforces so because you
can put more complex things in there I
think of it more as a query syntax where
lists and dictionaries have got very
simple syntax but series and data frames
have got a more complicated query syntax
but as per the language square brackets
means index operation
and the next intersection is other kinds
of plots so you might have noticed we
never specified what kind of what we
wanted
Pam is just defaults to if it's dot plot
and are you're doing over a series or a
data frame which is just a bunch of
series to do a time series plot
effectively it treats it like that now
different kinds of plots actually need
different kinds of data and this is
something that I think when you're
talking about bar charts and histograms
and stuff at school it isn't always
quite made explicit but you see I see a
lot of people making mistakes by just
thinking I've got some data and I want
to represent it in this way
and maybe the two of them don't actually
make sense together for example you
shouldn't just alright you could but
maybe it wouldn't make sense
just take all your data here and plot it
as a bar chart because arguably it's
continuous data maybe it's continuous
maybe it's not that's really where it
starts to get a bit blurry but for
example if we wanted to do a chart of
the temperature in each decade each
decade kind of could be thought of as a
independent singular value and so we
want to plot a bar chart of the
temperature in each decade going across
the thickness of the sheet so let's have
a little look at how we can do bar
charts so at its most simple I will do
the thing I just said I wasn't going to
and show you that you can do dot plot
and then before doing the brackets there
you can write bar dot plot bar and then
call that as a function it's a bit of a
weird syntax for people who are used to
Python but there is a way to make this
work you run that and it does a very
very very dense bar chart where
everything smash together and you can't
really see very well what's going on now
that's not a very useful thing to do
really we want to look at sort of a
simplified view of this here we've got
three or four hundred pieces of data bar
charts don't work well with that many
piece of data so you want to simplify
this down so let's let's delete that
cell and start again so I'm gonna
introduce while I'm technically juicing
bar charts and the names
a few other bits of syntax in here which
I think are are useful things to know
about so first of all we've got our data
frame if we want to get out just the
years from this data frame the years
here are in the index column they're not
a column by itself so we can't just do
square brackets index because there's
not a column called index instead
there's a shortcut which gives us the
index which is just dot index that gives
us back effectively a list of all of the
index values what we want to do to turn
this column here and group these by
decade is to have our table here and the
way we're going to do is we're going to
make a new column on the right-hand side
which has inside it the decade that each
row is in this first one I say 1650 1660
1660 1660 and so on up to 2010 2010 2010
all the way to 2019 being also 2010 and
to do that we're going to do a little
bit string manipulation and so I'm going
to sort of play along with this and if
people have any questions along the way
ask in the chat and I'll try and pay
attention to both windows at once but
otherwise I'm sure all my helpers will
keep up so we're gonna make a new series
which contains this column here but
turned into a string so DF dot index and
we're going to turn that into a series
returning into a series so that we can
add it as a new column now the index of
that new series has to match the one
we're going to insert it into so it has
to use this same index here so this is
very repetitive but DF dot index and if
you look at that now I forgot to import
pan is on the screen form
pandas import
series here we have index column values
column they are the same as each other
and the detail is integer however we
want to have these as strings because
we're going to be doing string like
things to them in a moment so we apply
to the data in that column the string
function looks the same but now the D
type has changed to
and this we are going to call years
because these are the years that are
that we're dealing with we're going to
take that and we are going to apply
another function to it and the way we're
going to apply this function something
you might not have come across and that
is a lambda function which is a way of
very concisely applying a bit of
information to something so this X here
is going to represent each year each row
from our series and so we're going to
take each row and that is going to be a
g-string which is four captures long
like one six five nine for example or
two zero one nine and we are going to
take the first three characters from it
and then add the string zero so we're
cutting off the unit's number from the
year and replacing it with a zero and if
we look at that wind up with 1650 1660
1666 so on 2010 2010 2010 2010 so this
is now our data which represents the
decade that we're in we can then go back
to our data frame and assign that series
we've just created with the decade
strings to the decade column so it's
going to make a new column called decade
and so now when we look at dear dot head
we see we have a new column decade which
has 1650 1660 1660 and so on and so on
so in order to plot our data by decade
we first had to make a column which
represents a sort of a consistent piece
of information for each row we want to
group together because the next piece of
the next thing we want to do to our data
I think you can do in pandas which we
haven't come through yet but I'm going
to introduce now is grouping so if you
have a table of data you can group
together rows based on certain
conditions in example earlier we have
that continental column we created based
on whether the city was or was not
London
so we might for example want to group
our table had earlier by is this
Continental or is it not then we could
look for getting summary statistics for
one group summary statistics for the
other and then we can compare the two
against each other in our case here we
want to find some realistics by grouping
together based on the decade we want to
have one we're gonna make a new table
which has one row per decade and the row
per decade is going to be made up by
averaging the stuff that I'm in the rows
that are inside said decade so to group
things in pandas we do DF & the DF is
this table here
dr. grouped by decade if you just give a
column name it will group by all the
values that are the same in this column
here so it will make one group which
contains this one vote here 1650 it will
make another group which contains all of
the ones that are 1616 another row which
retains all the 1670s 1680s 1690s and so
on it will end up with one group per
decade then we tell it what we want to
do to each group if we just look what we
get here you see it gives us back not a
table which has the groupings in but
some kind of intermediate object and
that's done for performance reasons but
we can tell it now what do we want to do
to each of those groups we want to find
the mean of each group and when we run
that we get back this so you see here it
made a new data frame this is not the
same data famous before the index is now
based on the thing that we grouped by so
the decade is now the index because we
told it to group by decade and so it's
taken that to mean behave is the
important thing so use that index our
data
it's then made a row for each decade
where the values in that row for example
this 2.60 here is made up by averaging
all of the rows from the previous table
which are in the 1660 decade so 0 5 5 1
and then
some more that are hidden down here so
that gives us 2.6 so this has given us a
table which is now actually small enough
to fit on the page these are all the
decades between the start and the finish
and those scrolling is difficult when
it's like this so let's change this to
dots head just the first few rows or dot
tail the last few rows good
Christopher's doing a brilliant job
keeping up with me in the chat the very
last thing we want to do is assign this
to a giver variable name let's call this
by decade I can never spell decade so
this variable here is that data frame
that we just saw by decade so if we call
dot plot on by decade we will get a line
plot over the decades just like we did
before BC now we've reduced the noise in
the data because we've averaged over the
values within each decade we don't want
to plot all of them we want to plot just
the year because you want to reduce the
data were plotting still this is where
we really see that would trend very very
clearly before it was slightly lost in
the noise but now you can clearly see
over the last hundred years the
temperature has shot up you could say
the same thing between 1880 and 1720 so
maybe they were worried as well but we
know there's a global trend now not just
a local one to make this into a bar plot
we follow a plot with dot bar and there
we have it a bar plot over the decades
so in summary to do a bar plot you just
follow the plot with a bar but you do
have to think about the kind of data
you're doing things to so if you want to
do group by you need something to group
it by and then you need to call the
group by function last thing on this
pandas driven plotting chapter I wanted
to cover was saving a plot to afar and I
saw that someone in the chat already got
to this point in having a go and they
were having issue so I'm gonna
go through it on the screen up here I'm
gonna delete that file because I don't
need that anymore so let's make a new
cell and let's see about how we go about
saving this file now in matplotlib like
in many tools that are around especially
in programming land there is often more
than one way to do it now a
well-designed API will give you one
clear and obvious way to do something
but it's not always possible to only
have one way to do it so I'm going to
show you a way to do this I'm sure that
some of you if you've done this thing
before have alternative methods but this
is the way that I've used and I think is
nice and reliable also it has the
advantage that it works outside of tubes
and notebooks so if you're doing your
plots just in normal Python scripts this
is going to work well there as well
so we start with our DF year dot plot it
plots it to the screen and we've got the
thing showing up however is close to the
screen has kind of got rid of the
context that was around it so I'm going
to show you now how to explicitly
specify some of the things that map plot
Liban pandas is assuming for you so the
way that map plot live works is it works
on these axes idea now on axes in
matplotlib terminology you can think of
as being a plot a single XY plot or 3d
plot or something like that
now matplotlib also allows you to have
multiple plots all on one page the
terminology uses for that is one page
which might have multiple plots in is
called a figure and then you have
multiple axes within a figure so if you
want to do multiple subplots on one page
you need to start thinking in terms of
figures and axes and that's going to
make your life much simpler so the way
that you would start by doing that is
calling the well first of all you'd have
to import map lot Lib mats plot Lib dot
it's it
dip and we just check something I always
forget this pipe lot pipe lot as prz so
because we're gonna be using that for
lead functionality directly in a moment
rather than just hand as interface to it
we have to explicitly import map not lib
until now pandas has been doing that for
us behind the scenes we then call PL T
dot subplots this is going to refer to
returned to us by default a figure which
has on inside it one subplot if you want
multiple subplots we could put in two
there and we get a figure with two
subplots or two axes by default it just
gives us one we give them names it
returns us to piece of information it
gives it the figure and the axis object
so the figure is the page axis is a plot
that we can start to draw by default
this plot here is empty there's nothing
inside it we want to plot our data into
this axes which is inside this figure
and we do that by passing the ax
argument to the plot function equals ax
so we run this again
you should look exactly the same as how
it did what happened subplots so it's
pure there we go
exactly how I did before if we change
that to two it's gonna complain because
we are came back one axis object but we
were asking for two but we can't do that
if you if you unpack the arguments once
we've got this we can then refer to this
figure object which knows about
everything that's inside it and so we
can end the line with fig save fig let
me give it a name my lot dot PNG let's
say and it's going to save that and you
see as I press that my plot dot PNG
appeared over here on the Left let's
move that happened by deleting it and
running that cell again it appears over
here you can open it up and we see this
is the plot
in markdown mode we can code markdown we
can then display that plot by using the
markdown syntax for showing a picture
which is my plot dot PNG and then it
shows up in markdown load this is a
picture so we can have hello by in front
of them behind it so that's how you say
figures and if you have your analysis
pipeline from reading in your file doing
your analysis all the way through to
saving your figure you can then run that
anytime and update all the plots in your
analysis in one go which is a really
really nice way of working so in the
last few minutes I'm not going to do any
more code because the very last section
in here if you go to the bottom of the
map for Lib chapter and press next
there's a section called making it
prettier so this section again I suggest
you have a look through in your own time
because there's quite a lot of very
dense code do email us if you have any
questions but to summarize with
matplotlib
you can go for making a plot which looks
like this which is using the default
colors default axis labels etc until you
get a plot excuse the scrolling that
looks like this so there we've changed
the axes we've changed the colors we've
added in labels and written mathematical
texts we've put in a late a legend and
it's able to present things in a nice
way so Matt what Lib gives you the
ability to do that but if I scroll up
just a little bit you see that the code
can sometimes be a little bit
complicated so have a look at this
section in your own time later on I tend
not to go through it in a class because
it's just a lot of repetitive stuff but
do have a look at this go through it
step by step
it should explain what's happening along
the way and you can see how you can
start to design your plots to be a
little bit better presented moving on to
the summary now that's the other thing I
want to store by the course basically so
thank you all for coming along today and
hopefully see you again
in a course in the future